you said something uh as i head out to
the first day on my last season finale
i can't help but be incredibly grateful
for all that supernatural and the spnf
family spnf espn family
yeah how much they mean to me it's been
an incredible journey to say the least i
for one am hoping that supernatural
never dies
what did you mean by that for which part
that was a long sentence i mean the part
where you hope supernatural never dies
you hope just hang on hang on is it a i
just want it to go on forever in terms
of
the fans will always remember it in 30
years from now when i walk into it you
know
oh my supernatural and it will just
always be in people's minds and
new to new generations is it that or is
it b
i'd like to come back and do a
supernatural movie or maybe we'll do
another season someday who knows or
is it a combination of both uh yes yes
yes and yes
um yeah it was a difficult
i knew i wanted to kind of send
something and not even for me like i'm
not a big
i'm not a big poster guy uh uh
posting on social media kind of guy
right like i just lose track it's not
that i don't i think there's a lot of
value in social media like
i i'd be lying if i didn't say i flipped
through instagram and and
twitter or whatever during takes um i
just don't think about it it's not
something i
i think i i don't know i'm trying to
psychoanalyze myself no
let me let me analyze you because i i by
just by knowing you
a little i could see that you're like
you're a family guy you get distracted
by life and nature and things and
yeah and just like like living you're
more in the present than you are
always on your phone where someone like
me lately i've been like you know
i'm on the phone i'm this and that and
i'm trying hence why i watched alone
and cry at every season and i call i
email jordan after i
direct message him this is why it works
sometimes you direct message people and
they're like [ __ ] off or they don't
respond
sometimes you go because hey i have a
podcast that i love and i think you know
people
it's an interesting and he immediately
goes man i love i'd love to be on the
show
that's amazing yeah man hey cool i'm a
big fan of his me too
and like a lot of people don't know but
look if you're listening to us listen to
the jordan jonas episode it's it's it's
great he's a great guy he's got a big
heart
and wait to hear his story i'm sure you
know some of it but anyway what's up
uh i promise you this man as soon as we
hang up i'm gonna listen to it oh you'll
love it yeah yeah he's
hilarious yeah yeah good good i think
you know what's funny is that i'm gonna
i'm gonna
push back just because i don't disagree
with you but i'm trying to
i'm trying to hash out my own feelings
but
you were saying that you know you you
lived in the moment for a while
i want to connect more that's what i'm
trying to do i want to connect more and
more
here's what i'll offer and here's what
i'm trying to deal with right now
you know saying goodbye to a friend of
15 years
the show you know my character sam like
i know so well i was
i was i've never gone i'm going on a
tangent a little bit
i've never gone five months without
playing same winchester not since i was
22 years old and i'm 38 now with a wife
and three kids
and gray hairs they have to scratch out
with a comb
uh very humbling but i would say this
man like
i think as actors hey and you know this
more than anybody
when they say okay rolling action
you have to be in the moment you have to
you can't think about like oh did i lock
my door
oh uh i should have called my friend oh
my god my
agent uh i was supposed to call him uh
five minutes ago oh my taxes are due you
have to live right there in the moment
and i think it sounds like and having
known you for a while
you're that kind of person anyways so
that's your nature but also your nurture
right here i mean michael rosenbaum on
sunday
at 11 19 uh
pacific time you have a thousand things
you could be doing
if you were just laying in your bathtub
you have a you have a thousand you know
a thousand might be hyperbole or
something
one one thing let's say
you have a dozen things that you could
be doing right like oh i gotta send this
text
my my three buddies text me when i was
asleep i gotta respond them all
um but now you're here with me and
you're with me and we're a thousand
miles away or whatever
on a computer but you're able to be
present and i think that's magical
there's a downside
to that there's a there's a second edge
to that sword right
where i'm really bad and you know this
and you've teased me and i think we've
teased each other i don't
answer phone calls i don't respond to
emails i don't respond to texts
i get him and then i like go back to set
or i get him and then
pick my kid back up and jump in the pool
right and i'll get to it later i'll get
to it later i'll get to it later
so i feel like one of these things is
we're sort of blessed and cursed
by this idea that we are good
at living in the moment and i guess i'm
grateful for it i guess i've had to
become grateful for because i don't have
another choice it is my nature it is my
nurture
um and so i don't know where i was
really going with this
uh other than to say um well about being
connected about being
why why you're on instagram thank you
yes so you were talking about your phone
and being on your phone
and i would say that you still connect
your phone i would i would argue
on your behalf that when you are on your
phone even if you're among
a million people uh there's a michael
buble song i used to listen to
season one sing it jared i was embracing
carol i ain't gonna sing it i don't
wanna i don't wanna tune out
but uh uh maybe surrounded by a million
people i still feel all alone
i wanna go home now that i'm feeling
alone but the idea that
yeah yeah you're a singer the idea that
you can be
in a in the most crowded room and still
be in your head
the idea that you can have a million
things to do and still choose to get on
your phone
it's part escapism i assume i don't know
i'm still learning
um but i think there's some magic also
too i'm going to commit
i'm on my phone i'm not going to send
just like smiley face emoji
i'm going to write something yeah like
hey my buddy texted me i'm going to
i'm going to uh process that i'm going
to take it in
i'm going to think of what i need to say
and i'm going gonna move forward so i
think
how are you 15 years yeah
i i hear what you're saying